so there was a senate hearing yesterday
involving a number of different public
health officials the new cdc director
rochelle walensky participated and so
did dr anthony fauci the top infectious
disease doctor
in the united states and a republican
senator rand paul was there
rand paul has been increasingly fixated
on a
covid lab leak conspiracy
and this all came to a spectacular head
yesterday when rand paul
i guess confronted dr fauci about it and
dr
fauci reacted by saying quite plainly
rand paul has no idea what the hell he's
talking about and we're going to pick it
up near the start and dive into it
uh let's go right into the first clip
think about that for a moment
the sars virus had a 15 mortality
we're fighting a pandemic that has about
a 1
mortality can you imagine if a sars
virus that's been
juiced up and had viral proteins added
to it to the spike protein
if that were released accidentally
dr fauci do you still support funding of
the
nih funding of the lab in wuhan
senator paul with all due respect you
are entitled entirely
and completely incorrect that the
nih has not ever and does not now
fund gain of function research
in the wuhan institute do they find dr
barrick
we do not fund do you find dr barracks
gain of function research
dr barrett does not doing gain or
function research and if it is
it's according to the guidelines and it
is being conducted in north
carolina i don't think it's concerning a
bad virus spike protein
okay so let's break down some of this
stuff it is
certainly possible that this wuhan
lab was researching coronaviruses
and even could have been researching
this specific coronavirus strain
in their lab and that should be looked
at
because it might have leaked in addition
to it already having been out in the
world
as an accident that's certainly possible
it should be
investigated what some people are going
to
is that this was a bio-engineered weapon
um amplified at the wuhan lab
and released into the public there is no
evidence of that whatsoever now
with all of these conspiracies one and
one can always say in conspiracists
typically do
you've not definitively proven that that
hasn't happened
but when you make the extraordinary
claim or when you make a claim
for which we have not seen evidence then
you should at least look for or present
some evidence if you want to be taken
seriously so this is like layer one of
the conspiracy
which is establishing as rand paul is
trying to do
that the nih and dr fauci himself in
some cases were
specifically funding research at the
wuhan lab but dr
fauci says we did not fund what is
called the gain
of function research if you don't know
what that term means
it's going to be hard to follow the rest
of this conversation
gain of function research is research
into making a microorganism
a virus etc have increased
transmissibility
increased virulence increased
immunogenicity
from what it has through a variety of
different processes
processes that can be done in a lab and
dr fauci simply says
that wasn't being done and we're not
funding that and dr fauci
was ready for what followed from rand
paul here that he got from the wuhan
institute into the sars viruses gain of
function
that is not a minority because at least
200
scientists have signed a statement from
the cambridge working group
saying that it is gain of function well
it is not
and if you look at the grant and you
look at the
progress reports it has not gained a
function
despite the fact that people tweet that
so you're trying to report sending money
to the wuhan virology institute
we do not send money now to do one hun
sending money we did under your tutelage
we were sending it through eco health it
was a sub agency
and a sub grant do you support the money
from nih that was going to the wuhan
institute
let me explain to you why that was done
the saws cov1 originated
in bats in china it would have been
irresponsible of us if we did not
investigate the bat viruses
and the serology to see who might have
been perhaps it would be in china
to send it to the child so dr fauci was
totally ready for that and rand paul
had to then scale back the question you
might have noticed okay okay okay
it wasn't that type of research but in
this particular case but do you support
sending any money uh to the wuhan
institute of virology and fauci says we
do not
and rand paul says well okay yeah but we
did and maybe
well the situation was related to sars
kovi one and of course we would fund
research where it originated that's an
important thing to understand
uh we were we were looking at sars kovi
one and we were looking at it where it
originated it makes sense to do that why
wouldn't we be doing that
okay so then they move on but rand paul
keeps pushing
at dr fauci stuff that is simply not
true
and fauci just keeps beating it off rand
paul goes back again to gain a function
research and voucher again has to beat
it but beat it back
absolutely in china possible to send it
to the chinese government that we may
not be able to trust with this uh
knowledge and with this uh incredibly
dangerous viruses
government scientists like yourself who
favor gain of function
i don't favor gain of function research
in china
that are not correct government
defenders of gain of function
such as yourself rand paul just won't be
deterred
right uh and and this is not it rand
paul
keeps going it starts to get painful
look at this
in the u.s we have 11 labs doing it and
you have allowed it here we have a
committee to do it but the committee is
granted every exemption
you're you're fooling with mother nature
here you're allowing super viruses to be
created
with a 15 percent mortality it's very
dangerous i think it was a huge mistake
to share this with china
and it's a huge mistake to allow this to
continue in the united states
and we should be very careful to
investigate where this virus came from
i fully agree that you should
investigate where the virus came from
but again we have not funded gain of
function
research on this virus in the wuhan
institute of virology
no matter parsing words your part say it
there was research done with dr she and
dr barrack they have collaborated on
gain of function research
where they enhanced the sars virus to
infect
human airway cells and they did it by
merging a new spike protein
on it that is gain of function that was
joint research between the wuhan
institute and dr barrack you can't deny
it
senator paul your time time has expired
dr fatchi i will let you respond to that
when
we need to move on excuse me
i will allow you to respond to that and
then we'll move on yeah i mean i just
wanted to say
we i i don't know how many times i can
say it madam chair
we did not fund gain of function
research to be conducted in the wuhan
institute
of virology thank you you almost don't
really need dr fauci there and this is a
typical
uh what sometimes the term grandstanding
is thrown around for what happens
in these senate hearings and one way
that i
identify grandstanding is that even
without
the the the guest or the witness or the
person giving testimony
you almost don't need them for the
senator to just keep doing what they're
what they do and saying what they say
they are going to say their peace
regardless
of what the witness contributes and rand
paul is just reading this stuff
regardless of what dr fauci says
and then lastly and this is really
important because of what it points to
senator tina smith who's a democrat from
minnesota
points out that line of questioning from
rand paul
when rand paul does that
it increases vaccine hesitancy take a
listen to this
thank you chair murray and thank you so
much to our
panelists for being here today um
i want to just following up on that
exchange
just ask dr fauci a question dr fauci
what is the impact of
conspiracy theories peddled by senator
rand paul and others
on americans willingness to up to take
this vaccine
a vaccine that by all accounts is
remarkable for its safety and efficacy
well conspiracy theories certainly are
not helpful in what we're trying to do i
guess i can say that with some degree of
confidence
well i would agree and i think and
that's exactly right dr
fauci is being extremely careful and
reserved in his language i get that
but this is a major problem when you
start to see these lines of questioning
particularly from senators like rand
paul who have such
wacky basis bases of support can we
trust
anything can we trust what science knows
about the origins of the virus can we
trust
what anybody tells us about vaccines or
the seriousness of the disease
about the need to get vaccinated about
anything and
dr fauci just doing everything he can
to try to resist these continued
propaganda efforts from people like rand
paul
and it is not merely an annoyance
because you and i know that if he were
not dealing with this
and if he had not been dealing with this
stuff for the last year plus
dr fauci could have done so much more by
focusing his energy elsewhere but
you have to fight this stuff off uh it's
also that
it gets this these narratives in to
people's minds
and then they don't get vaccinated or
they don't wear masks where they should
or whatever the case may be so
there's a real world impact here for
rand paul maybe it is performative
theater i don't know i don't really know
what's in rand paul
rand paul's head but it has a
destructive real world impact
one of our sponsors is privacy.com
they're giving you five dollars when you
sign up for their completely
free service at privacy.com
pacman i've been using privacy for a
little over a year now you've heard me
talk about it before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something online or on
the phone
instead of actually using your real
credit card number the privacy app and
the browser plug-in
let you give each company a randomized
virtual credit card number that you
create out of thin air it'll even
autofill the card number with one click
and the payment is taken out of your
checking account
without the merchant ever knowing your
real information so this allows you to
keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create
up to 12 of these virtual credit cards a
month you can set spending limits you
can freeze them
you can delete them anytime you want so
when you do this
it means you're not going to be charged
when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number
right after using it which for instance
i love using free trials because i know
i won't be charged when the trial is
over if i use a virtual credit card
number
you're keeping your identity private by
not telling companies who you are
you're keeping your bank or credit card
info protected against data breaches and
identity theft
and it's free and like i said you'll get
five dollars to spend when you sign up
at privacy.com slash pacman